[Music]
there's a video that's going around the
internet uh of a high school senior you
may have seen this of a high school
senior who's trying to get into yale
university okay she wants to get into
yale university so she wrote a song and
made a music video hoping it might help
her chances of getting into yale and
this clip has gone viral a lot of people
talking about it uh take a look
[Music]
[Music]
well it's uh obviously it's a catchy
song and uh
well the yale admissions office has seen
the video and we just found out they
just posted their own music video
response
on youtube it came out just a couple
hours ago and i think this is the first
look at it let's take let's see
we've completed evaluation
of your application and despite your
desperation we have no room for you
next time write a better essay do better
on your s.a.t make a large cast donation
or lie about your family tree
we didn't bother to learn your name
we're not impressed with internet fame a
viral video decides your fate good luck
next year at arizona state
you're not going to yeah
no no no no no no you're not going to
yeah
[Music]
they should have just sent her a letter
yeah
i'm gonna say that seems kind of dicky
yeah